NCIS' Michael Weatherly didn't initially
say why he left the show, but his real
reason for leaving was surprisingly romantic
— but not for the reasons you might expect!
Stars who have been a part of the show have all
had their disparate reasons for leaving – and
those reasons haven't always been transparent
from the start. Pauley Perrette, for example,
reportedly left after a workplace situation that
caused her discomfort led to conflict between her
and Mark Harmon, which wasn't revealed at the time
of her departure. Sasha Alexander, who played Kate
Todd, apparently felt the shooting schedule was
too difficult, which makes sense since the show is
infamous for long shooting days. Her replacement,
Cote de Pablo, felt her character wasn't getting
enough respect and the scripts weren't worthy
of her, as she revealed in a 2016 interview.
When Michael Weatherly left at the
end of the show's 13th season in 2016,
it was an emotional ending given
that his character, Tony DiNozzo,
was one of the original NCIS agents
and a major lead in the series.
"I'm going home to see Tali."
When Michael Weatherly's exit was announced,
no reason was given for his departure,
although The Hollywood Reporter linked the news to
an incident in which Weatherly pleaded no contest
to driving under the influence and was sentenced
to an alcohol recovery program. Over the years,
however, he's given a few reasons for leaving.
When announcing his new legal drama Bull,
he explained during the Television
Critics Association's press tour,
"I was burnt out by 'NCIS' and I
was ready for a new challenge."
He explained that he was
tired of the grind, saying,
"It really felt like a circle that
had gone all the way around and I
really felt happy with the resolution
of character and my time on the show."
He also told TV Insider that he was
experiencing wanderlust and that there
were other things he wanted to do. Plus,
he wished to spend time with his family,
which includes his physician wife Bojana
Jankovic, their children, and a son from
his previous marriage. NCIS is well known for
its long hours. Actor Sean Murray told StarryMag
in 2020 that the average workday was 12 hours for
the actors, which was an improvement over previous
years. As noted, those hours drove colleague
Sasha Alexander away after just two seasons.
So this wasn't surprising — Weatherly had,
after all, been on the show for 13 seasons.
But Michael Weatherly has also said he had
another reason for leaving, one that was
more romantic. It has everything to do with
the romance between his character and Ziva.
"I did not want you to find me, and yet you did."
Their sexual tension ignited in the third season
and continued its slow and sometimes frustrating
burn throughout the seasons until Cote de Pablo
announced her departure and her character was
killed off — except, she wasn't really dead.
Watchers of the show know that DiNozzo later
discovered that he and Ziva had a child and when
Tony left, it was to take care of their daughter.
"Well, thank God for the go-bag, right?"
In the TV Insider interview, Weatherly noted
that he started thinking about leaving after
de Pablo left in NCIS' 11th season.
The reason? He told the publication,
"Their great dynamic, the badinage and
sparring and flirting between those
two characters and how they would swing from
siblings to near lovers and back to buddies,
that was gone, and then I got to the point
where I felt I'd stayed at the party for too
long. I would look around the room and other
people were really in sync and having fun."
De Pablo has since made several guest appearances
on NCIS, revealing that Ziva had actually faked
her death. She and DiNozzo were apparently
reunited in 2019, although technically Weatherly
hasn't been seen on the series since he departed.
However, the actor posted a recent New Year's
tweet hinting that an on-screen reunion might be
coming in 2023. Fans will want to stay tuned.